Donald Trump said that he would appoint
a special prosecutor to investigate
Democratic presidential nominee Hillary
Clinton's use of a private email server
you probably have heard that story
before that is probably not news to you
now during that time Donald Trump helped
to popularize the chant lock her up
however we recently heard from Donald
Trump that that was just election BS it
was something that plays well during the
campaign but that we don't care about it
now in other words what Trump met was it
something I said to get people excited
and to vote for me but I never really
planned to do it now a lot of this email
thing also extended to Trump's incoming
cabinet members and advisors and this
includes none other than retired Army
General Michael Flynn he condemned
Hillary Clinton's quote careless use of
a private private email server and said
that there was quote nothing wrong with
the lock her up chance let me put up a
quote for you from michael Flynn we're
saying that because if I a guy who knows
this business if i did a tenth a tenth
of what she did i would be in jail today
so so crooked Hillary Clinton leave this
race now well sometimes irony is sweet
but in some cases it's not because this
guy still going to be national security
adviser it turns out that michael Flynn
did do a tenth of what Hillary Clinton
actually did Flynn himself
inappropriately shared classified
information with foreign military
officers and officials in Afghanistan in
2010 as the Washington Post reported
just 48 hours ago Flynn wasn't
authorized to share the classified
information he was not authorized to
share the particular secrets that he
divulged now Flynn was asked about this
and he said this is insignificant uh
this is nothing that we need to worry
about yet there are numerous former US
officials that are familiar with exactly
what Flynn did which say that who say
that he is accused of telling a lies
about the activities of other agencies
in Afghanistan including the CIA this is
very serious but it gets even more
interesting Pat remember the clin
in private email server situation Dana
priest wrote a profile Flynn in The New
Yorker and reported that Flynn quotes
had technicians secretly install and eat
an internet connection in his Pentagon
office even though it was forbidden well
lock a lot right Pat but you see on you
know servers are more likely to be
hacked at home then you know at my
office because uh you know Hilary was a
crook or something like that yeah it's a
total double standard and also your
member General David Petraeus shared
very highly classified information oh
yeah not for the interest of the public
but just to show it off to his
biographer and his lover indeed and
Petraeus was considered for a long time
for Secretary of State someone should
alert jason Chaffetz because I'm sure
just like he started up a congressional
investigation into Hillary's email
scandal he'll start one into michael
Flynn right away right i mean we know he
takes this type of thing very very
seriously oh wait no it was all a
partisan witch hunt from the beginning
imagine if michael Flynn as part of the
trump administration exposed for example
classified information to one of our
adversaries like I don't know Russia or
something wait is Russia and adversary
now or they someone that half of trumps
cabinet is friendly with and would love
to do business with I don't know it's
changed so quickly since Mitt Romney
called Russia our greatest geopolitical
foe in 2012 that it's hard for me to
know whether Russia's even bad right now
yeah I can't really answer that question
for you this is a very very hot topic on
our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash read it re d di t you
can discuss this story or any others
from today's show there warby parker is
offering a free five day home try-on to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses i personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try-on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trial
dot-com / TDPS I don't really like going
into glass
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / tdps it costs nothing